foreign
stock market Bowl you're probably
rooting for Republicans to win big in
the midterms that's according to the
latest Bloomberg survey of professional
and Retail investors it found that more
than a third of respondents see the GOP
went in control of both the House and
Senate as the best outcome for U.S
stocks over the next three months only
about one out of five expect stocks to
rise if Democrats manage to keep their
leads in Congress and if there are
highly contested outcomes or Worse
social unrest more than a third of
respondents say that would send stocks
falling here's why the stock market
favors a GOP Congress this time around
investors on the whole like political
gridlock actually what they really like
is business as usual and a split
government gets them there a president's
policy agenda often ends up stalling out
which means fewer consequential laws
will be passed this then removes one
source of uncertainty in a world where
War disease and widening inequality are
all pressuring the global economy there
is one thing that might benefit if the
Democrats keep control of Congress the
dollar here's the rationale it'd be
easier for Dems to pass legislation to
boost social programs and government
funding that spending tends to be
inflationary which would keep interest
rates elevated increasing the Dollar's
appeal relative to other currencies
[Music]